wir sind in der schweiz im tiefsten
winter es ist ein ständiger kampf gegen
die elemente den bernina express am
rollen zu halten jede fahrt ist ein
hindernisparcours in den bergen wird nie
langweilig heftiger schneefall es ist
sehr windig eine starke vereisung und
steinschlag eine enorme herausforderung
für zugführer sicherheit geht vor aber
die landschaft ist atemberaubend schön
auch wenn sie es dem zug alles andere
als leicht macht zeit für eine
lawinensprengungen die eine
abenteuerliche reise durch die schweizer
alpen
majestätisch aufragende schneebedeckte
berge die schweiz im winter
[Musik]
die schienen durch diese berge wurden
vor über 100 jahren verlegt steile hänge
schnee und eis es war ein knochenjob
die reise beginnt in chur im kanton
graubünden
am bahnhof freuen sich skifahrer
touristen und die zugbegleiter auf die
abfahrt
hallo patricia guten morgen teddy
ich bin aufgeregt ich freue mich total
auf die reise als zugbegleiterin sind
sie für alle an bord verantwortlich ist
es heute voll ja ziemlich es sind um die
200 leute
die passagiere freuen sich auf eine der
malerischsten strecken der welt
damit der zug die anspruchsvolle fahrt
durch die berge auch meistern kann
nehmen wartungsteam scene ganz genau
unter die lupe
der stromabnehmer bekommt gerade eine
neue kontakt leiste für die
energiezufuhr aus der oberleitung
man sieht wie dünn sie geworden ist
der zug wird von oben bis unten sehr
genau gecheckt
wir prüfen ob die räder auch keine risse
haben einbruch kann zur katastrophe
führen
und eine entgleisung ist das letzte was
man auf dem höchsten eisenbahn pass in
den alpen erleben möchte
sieht alles gut aus
damit ist der bernina-express offiziell
bereits zur abfahrt
um die alpen zu bezwingen braucht es
jahrelange erfahrung und nerven wie
drahtseile beides hat lokführer reto
mathieu hallo hallo teddy freut mich was
ist das schwierigste an ihrem job das
wetter hält immer reichlich action parat
ich gehe davon aus dass es noch einen
schneesturm geben wird die fahrt wird
turbulent und aufregend
das schwierigste ist auf der langen
fahrt die ganze zeit konzentriert zu
bleiben
ok dann legen sie mal los
[Applaus]
alle kontrollen sind erledigt der zug
ist voller touristen unsere reise durch
die alpen kann beginnen
wie viele schnell und pendlerzüge nutzt
der bernina-express statt einer
lokomotive einen elektro triebzug
im beiwagen und den zwei triebwagen
finden insgesamt 100 passagiere platz
die triebwagen sind je 16 meter fünfzig
lang drei meter 80 hoch und 2 meter 65
breit
angekoppelt sind sechs weitere
personenwagen mit panoramafenstern
die abfahrt ist für 8 uhr 32 geplant und
wenn die schweizer 8 uhr 32 sagen dann
meinen sie es
damit beginnt die vierstündige reise auf
zwei historischen strecken die zum
unesco-welterbe gehören
von chur geht es nach thusis dort
beginnt die atemberaubende albula linie
die ins mondäne sankt moritz fährt
in pontresina erfolgt dann der wechsel
auf die berninalinie
nach dem hospiz bernina dem höchsten
punkt auf der reise geht es bergab durch
malerische tal dörfer und schließlich
nach tirano in italien
wir sind erst vor ein paar minuten in
chur losgefahren und es ist jetzt schon
unglaublich diese landschaft das ist
doch berühmt für eine der höchsten
burgen dichten in ganz europa hier
fließt auch der rhein dessen verlauf wir
gerade folgen
230.000 passagiere genießen jedes jahr
die beeindruckende aussicht an bord
und sie sind in guten händen
ich genieße meine arbeit jeden tag die
sicherheit steht natürlich an oberster
stelle aber es macht auch spaß
weniger spaß hatte strecken meister adam
long partie bei seinem arbeitsbeginn um
fünf uhr früh
es ist kalt heute wir sind die arbeit
hier draußen gewohnt haben mögen es
gerne warm das ist eben der job von
kathi arbeitet seit 30 jahren auf dieser
strecke er ist für den 61 kilometer
langen abschnitt von thusis nach sankt
moritz verantwortlich sein job ist es
dafür zu sorgen dass die züge nicht
steckenbleiben die tunnel sind sehr eng
und die züge breit
alles vereist sehen sie das grundwasser
sickert in die risse im tunnel ein und
gefriert dort das verringert den
spielraum auf beiden seiten im winter
muss das team mindestens zweimal pro
woche mit spitzhacken gegen die
vereisung ankämpfen
ok sammeln wir das eis ein
die männer schaufeln die eisbrocken in
den wagen und wenden sich dann der decke
zu
herabfallende eiszapfen könnten auf die
windschutzscheibe treffen und den fahrer
verletzen
also muss das team die gefahrenquellen
entfernen
wir sind stabil wir sind stark das
halten wir aus wenn der helm hält
passiert ja nichts
kommt es zu vereisungen an den
stromleitungen könnten alle züge auf
dieser einspurigen strecke liegen
bleiben
das eis zerstört nicht die leitungen
aber der stromabnehmer der die
elektrizität in den zug leitet geht
kaputt und das war's dann
die spannung auf den oberleitungen
beträgt 11 1000 volt
dafür braucht das team eine
spezialausrüstung aus kohlefaser
die stangen schützen uns vor
stromschlägen so dass wir sicher
arbeiten können ohne den strom
abzuschalten sie kosten 1500 schweizer
franken pro stück
ein kleiner preis für die sicherheit in
einem job der sonst schnell tödlich sein
könnte
meine familie macht sich schon manchmal
sorgen um mich
letztes jahr wurde ich fast von einem
zug angefahren
ein kollege hat mich gerade noch an der
schulter wegziehen können
[Musik]
der bernina express ist derweil auf der
117 jahre alten albula linie unterwegs
pfarrer reto steuert die bahn und
zugbegleiterin patricia guten morgen
hallo
sorgt dafür dass sich die passagiere
wohl fühlen
der zug passiert vereinzelte häuser und
bahnhöfe entlang der strecke aber dann
wird die landschaft weit und es sind nur
noch berge zu sehen
was sind ihre aufgaben auf dem weg nach
tirano die wichtigste ist für sicherheit
zu sorgen
das ist auch in der leitstelle in
landquart die oberste priorität
der bernina express fährt von gleis 68
über gleich 57 bis zu gleis 10 das hier
ist die schaltzentrale unsere
schienennetzes
hier überwachen disponenten und
fahrdienstleiter die zugstrecken sie
arbeiten für die rhätische bahn kurz rhb
die eigentümerin des bernina express und
des größten alpinen schienennetzes der
schweiz
ein drittel unserer strecken verlaufen
auf über 1500 metern höhe also in
alpinem gebiet für züge werden große
höhen enorme herausforderungen
bei starkem schneefall müssen wir
manchmal den verkehr einstellen weil es
zu lawinen kommen kann
die letzten 85 jahren starben bei
lawinenabgängen in der schweiz fast 2000
menschen
[Musik]
darum beschäftigt das bahnunternehmen
ein team aus schnee experten sie
untersuchen das schnee fällt oberhalb
der schienen das zum problem werden
könnte wir untersuchen wie stabil der
hang ist und ob der zug sicher passieren
kann
wir haben diese zwei kilogramm schwere
sonde die je nach dichte und härte der
schneeschicht mehr oder weniger tief
einsinkt
es ist eine wirklich harte schicht ist
es ja bei einer mischung aus harten und
weichen schichten entsteht eine sehr
gefährliche situation
das ganze schneebrett kann sich lösen
und ab gehen aber das team vertraut
nicht allein auf die sonde es werden
auch einzelne schneekristalle untersucht
rundere kristalle halten besser zusammen
und sorgen für eine stabilere
schneedecke im moment sieht es gut aus
auch die temperatur spielt eine rolle
je größer der temperaturunterschied
desto mehr verändert sich die
schneedecke
bei einem unterschied von mehr als einem
grad celsius auf 10 cm muss das team
gegebenenfalls aktiv werden
auf dann müssten wir den zug anhalten im
moment beträgt der unterschied nur neun
grad im gesamten abschnitt von oben bis
unten
heute sieht alles gut aus
die züge können also weiter fahren
allerdings müssen die ergebnisse noch
durch einen abschließenden test
bestätigt werden den rutsch blog er wird
in den siebziger jahren hier in der
schweiz entwickelt dabei wird mit hilfe
einer schnur ein schnee blog
abgeschnitten
jetzt belastet den block mit meinem
gewicht aber ohne zu springen
3 wie ein abgang als nächstes stelle ich
mich an die schnittkante und springe auf
den block
1 23
das war's wenn er einem sprung stand
hält es der sehr stabil der riss in der
schicht ist auch genau dort aufgetreten
wo wir damit gerechnet haben da es keine
überraschungen gibt kann die strecke
weiter befahren werden das gefällt uns
wir mögen keine überraschungen in diesen
job
aber ein stück weiter könnte sich die
lage anders darstellen
der traditionsreiche bernina express ist
auf dem weg in richtung sankt moritz
als diese bahnstrecke anfang des letzten
jahrhunderts gebaut wurde erlebte diese
region einen boom aber schienen über die
berge zu verlegen war für die schweizer
ingenieure eine riesenherausforderung
wer wüsste das besser als jordan geraten
der eisenbahn enthusiast hat seine
doktorarbeit über die geschichte des
alpentourismus geschrieben
es gab keine vernünftigen straßen bis
nach sankt moritz dadurch dauerte die
anreise aus italien oder kur ewig acht
stunden mit pferden das änderte sich
durch die bahn
der bau der albula bahn beginnt im jahr
fünf jahre lang schlagen mehr als 4000
arbeiter 42 tunnel in den fels und bauen
144 brücken und viadukte über täler
fasziniert dass sie nach wie vor dass es
in dieser umgebung eine zugstrecke gibt
es gibt viele andere zugstrecken durch
die alpen und andere gebirge in europa
aber meist verlaufen sie durch täler das
beeindruckende an der albula bahn ist
dass sie über flüsse und schluchten
verläuft das macht sie so interessant
aber auch ziemlich gefährlich für die
überwindung von über 1000 höhenmetern
werden die gleise mit einem sanften
anstieg von dreieinhalb prozent verlegt
angepasst an die leistung von dampfloks
trotz der bescheidenen technologie und
fehlenden sicherheit haben sie das
möglich gemacht ein echtes wunder werk
genau wie das viadukt dass der zug jetzt
überqueren wird
sie vor und sehe ich schon dass so lisa
viadukt ein beeindruckendes bauwerk oder
ja es ist das höchste viadukt auf der
gesamten strecke
hier bieten wir den gästen einer langsam
fahrt
das viadukt wird 1901 aus hiesigem
kalkstein erbaut es ist 85 meter hoch
und überspannt den fluss albula ein
hilfsmittel das ein drachen töten der
märtyrer offenbar nicht brauchte der
legende zufolge sprang der heilige georg
auf der flucht mit seinem pferd über die
schlucht es ist eine legende aber
heutzutage haben wir dafür die bahn
die ingenieure entwerfen den bau mit elf
bögen so wird das viadukt stabiler und
weniger material intensiv das konzept
bewährt sich
[Musik]
beim runterschauen wurde mir schwindelig
ich gebe es zu das kenne ich
auf der albula linie folgt ein bauliches
meisterwerk dem anderen
verlangt das land wasser viadukt wurde
völlig ohne gerüste erbaut einfach so
von unten in die höhe
ein gerüst wäre vom fluss weggerissen
worden also erbaut man 1901 stahl türme
um die herum stein feiler gemauert
werden
die bauzeit des landwasser viadukt ist
doppelt so lang wie bei den anderen
viadukten entlang der strecke
das ist cool wir fahren jetzt über das
land wasser viadukt seht ihr das ist
eine der beeindruckendsten und
berühmtesten eisenbahn konstruktionen
der welt
2009 wird das viadukt saniert es dauert
neun monate die fugen im mauerwerk zu
verstärken dabei queren weiterhin 60
züge pro tag das bauwerk
weiter geht die fahrt durch verschneite
landschaften
mit dieser maschine halten wir die
strecke frei von schnee sie ist unser
ganzer stolz die kann was
mit ihren acht zylindern und 600 ps
räumt die große schneeschleuder die
strecke
pro stunde räumen wir etwa 3800
kubikmeter schnee
damit könnten sie in nur einer stunde
fast zwei olympische schwimmbecken mit
schneefällen
ok perfekt super
[Musik]
die schienen sind jetzt zwar frei aber
das team hat noch lange nicht feierabend
der zog steuert auf den ruck lux tunnel
zu er wurde 1903 nach einer
unterirdischen quelle angelegt
es läuft eine menge wasser in den tunnel
wasser das in den tunnel sickert und
dort an der kalten luft zu eis gefriert
kann die schienen verformen und so die
entlassungs gefahr erhöhen
deshalb wird der tunnel im jahr 1929 mit
ohren verschlossen sie verhindert die
gefährlichen - gerade im inneren
die tore sind signal gesteuert wenn sich
der zug nähert springt das signal auf
grün und die tunnel tore gehen
automatisch auf
automatisch
vorausgesetzt sie werden nicht blockiert
also sorgen lombardi und sein team für
freie schienen
hier wird ständig schnell eingeblasen
den müssen wir von hand weg räumen damit
die tore genug platz zum öffnen und
schließen haben
sobald die tore inspiziert sind und der
schnee geräumt ist springt das signal
auf grün
der raw knox tunnel ist der erste von
drei sogenannten kreis kehrt tunneln auf
dieser strecke
es geht darum auf kurzer strecke viel an
höhe zu gewinnen
genau das ist ein meisterwerk der
baukunst
wir müssen an höhe gewinnen haben dafür
aber nicht viel platz also fahren wir
eine schleife um bergauf zu kommen
bei der ausfahrt aus dem tunnel hat der
zug eine 360 grad kurve passiert und er
hat noch einige höhenmeter vor sich fast
so viele wie das empire state building
hoch ist aber das ist auf dieser kurzen
strecke nicht machbar die lösung eine
reihe von schleifen durch diese
bergflanke zieht sich der 6 167 meter
lange tunnel
nur 50 meter darüber folgt mit schweizer
präzision der
535 meter lange zwei tunnel
wahnsinn oder wir gewinnen in einem
tunnel an höhe wir fahren eine schleife
und sind innerhalb von sekunden an einem
höheren punkt als zuvor
die albula bahn befördert tausende
touristen auf völlig neue höhen
vielen dank das perfekte getränk für die
perfekte fahrt
aber es drohen auch lebensgefährliche
lawinen
hier kommt bergungsexperten hans
liebherr fuß ins spiel
freut mich ebenfalls
per fuß ist in den alpen geboren und
helikopterpilot in zweiter generation
er hat über 10.000 flugstunden und gut
drei jahrzehnte routine in diesen bergen
um in den bergen zu fliegen braucht man
viel erfahrung
im auftrag der rhätischen bahn
inspiziert er die zugstrecke aus der
luft um für sicherheit zu sorgen
was sehen wir hier gerade unter uns
das sind lawinenverbauungen die die rhb
strecke sichern
gibt es viele davon in den bergen
doch überall ja denn die gesamte rhb zug
strecke verläuft durch täler entlang der
berghänge und
damit sind lawinen eine ständige gefahr
für die züge
definitiv
man sieht dass wir hier über einem
lawinengebiet sind und auch wo die
lawinen abgehen da ist auch ein tunnel
so dass die bahnstrecke von lawinen
geschützt ist
näher an den schienen sieht man auch die
letzte schutzmaßnahme
hier fährt der bernina-express unterhalb
von schnee fangzaun entlang diese zäune
stehen überall auch direkt oberhalb der
schienen wie man hier sieht
aber das bahnunternehmen tut nicht nur
alles um lawinen umzulenken und
aufzuhalten es löst sie auch ganz
bewusst aus
die zeit für eine lawinensprengungen
der bernina-express bahnt sich seinen
weg durch die rauen schweizer alpen eine
anspruchsvolle zugstrecke die passagiere
aus aller welt anzieht
sie ist unsere verwandte aus der ukraine
das ist mein geburtstagsgeschenk eine
fahrt im bernina express ich finde es
toll
die amerikaner floyd und melissa lassen
hier ihre rucksacktour in den 90ern
wieder aufleben wir kamen damals müde
und erschöpft in der schweiz an es
gefiel uns aber wir hatten nur einen tag
zeit wir mussten zurück jetzt wollten
wir 25 jahre später noch mal herkommen
dieses mal etwas luxuriöser viel besser
und wir haben weniger gepäck eine tolle
geschichte der zug fährt durch das
engadin bekannt vor allem durch die
wintersport hochburg sankt moritz vom
zug aus hat man alles im blick
[Musik]
wie hat die bahnanbindung den tourismus
beeinflusst
die anfänge des wintersports gehen hier
bis 1864 zurück die bahn kamen 40 jahre
später sie hat großen anteil daran dass
sankt moritz zu einem wintersport mekka
wurde
jetzt steht der wechsel von der albula
auf die berninalinie an
wir halten am bahnhof pontresina und das
ist ein ganz besonderer halt denn hier
muss der zug sein stromsystem von
wechsel auf gleichstrom umstellen
während die albula linie mit
wechselstrom betrieben wird nutzt die
berninalinie gleichstrom früher mussten
dafür die loks getauscht werden aber der
bernina express kann mit beidem fahren
reto muss nur den stromabnehmer
einfahren während die oberleitung auf
gleichstrom umgeschaltet wird
kann ich den stromabnehmer wieder
rausfahren ja kann losgehen dankeschön
der stromabnehmer wird wieder
ausgefahren damit lässt er zog
wechselstrom und die albula linie hinter
sich weiter geht es auf der berliner
linie
sie wurde mit weniger mitteln tunneln
und brücken errichtet ist aber nicht
minder beeindruckend und verläuft sehr
hoch die berliner linie ist nicht nur
doppelt so steil wie die albula linie
ihre kurven sind auch länger
hinter der nächsten kurve beschleunige
ich nach dem langsamen abschnitt wieder
auf 50 kilometer pro stunde
seit der abfahrt in chur hat der
berliner express gut 1300 fordernde
höhenmeter erklommen
mit diesem zug erlebt man täglich etwas
neues
ist es stürmisch mal eisig und dann im
sommer ist alles ganz anders
anstrengend für den zug und seinen
fahrer und ein traum für passagiere die
es auf die piste zieht
[Musik]
wir sind hier in bernina diavolezza
einem beliebten skiort
[Musik]
dieser streckenabschnitt richtung aus
bio bernina hat mehr schnee als alle
anderen im winter 2001 lag er hier
sechseinhalb meter hoch
das wetter ist der chef
es beschert uns jeden tag etwas anderes
und neues
stefano crameri ist als strecken meister
der bernina linie dafür verantwortlich
dass der zug überall gut durchkommt
dafür setzt er auf große kaliber wir
können mit der fräse loslegen bestätige
loslegen mit der fräse
diese mächtige maschine mit dem
spitznamen monster ist so groß dass sie
von einem 2500 ps starken bauzug
geschoben werden muss entlang der
schienen kämpft sich das zweiergespann
durch die raue natur
wenn wir unseren job nicht machen kommt
der zug nicht durch auch ohne die
fähigkeiten der fahrer und
maschinenführer die tagtäglich ihre
arbeit machen wäre das nicht möglich
die großen schaufeln drehen sich 460 mal
pro minute und transportieren den schnee
in die maschine und weg von der strecke
das monster kann in einer stunde über
77.000 tonnen schnee räumen
das problem ist der wind nicht der
schnee
der wind trägt den schnee her und den
müssen wir dann räumen
das ist das hauptproblem
aber wind bläst nicht nur schnee auf die
schienen er kann auch züge entgleisen
lassen
2400 kilowatt treiben den bernina
express bei seinem aufstieg über den
gewaltigen berninapass in den schweizer
alpen an den bernina express gibt es
wohl keine langweiligen tage oder
momente absolut einzug in den bergen da
wird es nie langweilig für mich ist das
der schweizerischen zug überhaupt wir
fahren durch ein gebiet in dem drei der
vier amtssprachen der schweiz gesprochen
werden und dass einige der
beeindruckendsten landschaften zu bieten
hat für mich ist das die ultimative
reise in der schweiz wenn nicht sogar in
der ganzen welt
der zug windet sich entlang der ufer des
lago bianco er wird von gletschern
gespeist und ist die meiste zeit des
jahres zugefroren ein beliebtes foto
motiv auf über 2000 meter nähert sich
der zug jetzt dem gipfelpunkt der heise
wir kommen zum offizier bernina dem
höchsten punkt der strecke er macht sie
zur höchsten bahnlinie europas ohne
zahnstangen antrieb das ist schon
beeindruckend
um große steigungen zu überwinden nutzen
die meisten züge wie der schwester zug
des bernina express der glacier express
einen zahnstangen antrieb am unterboden
ist ein sich drehendes zahnrad befestigt
das an einer zahnspange zwischen den
bahnschienen ansetzt
der bernina-express nutzt ausschließlich
adhäsion also die reibung die zwischen
den zug rädern und den schienen entsteht
man braucht also kontakt zur schiene
dass es nicht immer so leicht
aktion funktioniert am besten auf
sauberen trockenen schienen schnee
zwischen schiene und zu grad verringert
die adhäsion kraft bei beschleunigung
auf nassen schienen können die achsen
und räder durchdrehen und von den
schienen rutschen
es ist also ein thema beim bernina
express
damit so etwas nicht geschieht müssen
die wartungs teams ständig schnee und
eismassen im auge behalten und entfernen
vor allem an den weichen
wenn so eine weiche hier verreist kann
der zug entgleisen
wenn er darauf ins rutschen kommt
also müssen wir sie eisfrei halten
anders als auf sonstigen schienen
abschnitten gibt es bei weichen
bewegliche teile um den zug von einem
gleis aufs andere zu leiten und die
müssen natürlich auch beweglich bleiben
daher sind an 103 wichtigen weichen
entlang der strecke heizsysteme
installiert
wir haben eine automatische systeme im
einsatz das hier
und es wird bei schneefall aktiv
bei feuchtigkeit oder einer temperatur
unter 25 grad celsius werden die
schienen automatisch beheizt
aber nicht alles lässt sich mit hilfe
der technik verhindern
orkanartige winde sind keine seltenheit
in den alpen
2018 lassen böen mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 200 km h an der lenk
im berner oberland einen zug entgleisen
acht passagiere werden dabei verletzt
der zug hat den bahnhof aus bio bernina
erreicht heute herrscht hier kein
starker wind aber es droht eine noch
größere gefahr
lawinen sind ein echtes risiko für den
bernina express
spezialisten kümmern sich darum mit
dynamit
in ihrer zentrale in samedan bereiten
die experten ein 125 kilogramm
sprengstoff vor
wir fertigen 5 kilogramm sprengladungen
an das hier sind die elektrischen zünder
sie entzünden die lunte die wiederum den
sprengstoff zündete
die fachmänner arbeiten für ortschaften
und skigebiete in der region aber heute
liegt ihr augenmerk auf den schienen der
rhätischen bahn
okay wir können los
[Musik]
die kontrollierte lawinenauslösung hat
sich seit den anfängen der bahn zu
beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
enorm weiterentwickelt genau wie die
sprengstoffe selbst
in den anfangstagen unserer flugeinsätze
nahm wir einfach irgendeinen sprengstoff
wickelten ihnen plastiktüten und
steckten ihn in flaschen träger
heute wird der sprengstoff in einer
speziellen sicherheits kiste mit schnell
löse vorrichtung gelagert für den fall
der fälle
bei einer notlandung können wir die
ganze kiste einfach rauswerfen
[Musik]
der sprengstoff ist verstaut und wir
sind bereit für den start
das team muss einen berg von schnee in
den griff bekommen bevor er zum problem
wird
unterwegs auf historische strecke durch
die schweizer alpen bei ihrem bau war
die berninalinie eigentlich nur für eine
nutzung im sommer vorgesehen dass ich
ihre fahrkarten sehen bitte
heute braucht selbst der hochmoderne
bernina-express jede verfügbare hilfe um
mit den gefahren des winterwetters
zurechtzukommen
wir sind unterwegs zur sprechstelle
lawinenexperten haben einen instabilen
abschnitt in der schneedecke an diesem
berghang ausgemacht
noch etwa 1 kilometer noch
wird nicht gesprengt
wir überfliegen das gebiet um
sicherzustellen dass keine tiere oder
menschen in der nähe sind
nachdem erkundungsflug
wir warten auf die freigabe durch die
schweizer armee lösen sie eine kleine
lawine aus um zu verhindern dass sich
unkontrolliert eine größere löst
erstmal gehen wir unter
können wir da richtung fällt
dann zünde ich jetzt ja zünden sünder
ist weg
ok ladung ist weg
okay gut
und ladung ist weg
nach der zündung bleiben ihnen nur 90
sekunden um das weite zu suchen
wir fliegen jetzt in einen sicheren
bereich und beobachten das ganze
bei der explosion lösen sich instabile
schneeschichten
beide haben lawinen ausgelöst
das war also ein erfolg
der bernina-express steuert den kleinen
bahnhof alb grün an er liegt im
deutschsprachigen teil der schweiz
nördlich der italienischen grenze
man weiß nie welche sprache man hier
sprechen soll die leute reden
französisch deutsch italienisch ja aber
englisch beherrschen alle also ja klar
beeindruckende gipfel wohin man blickt
eine spektakuläre aussicht aber
im zug hat patrizia ein problem mit der
stromversorgung entdeckt
funktioniert nicht ich versuche das
problem zu lösen denn hier passiert
nichts
auch die toilette funktioniert nicht
vier kilometer weiter gibt es ein echtes
problem die einhausung der skala galerie
füllt sich mit heran wie in dem schnee
das problem entsteht wenn es tagelang
wendig ist der zug trägt den schnee noch
weiter in den tunnel während er
hindurchfährt hier drin ist es so eng
dass keine maschinen eingesetzt werden
können der schnee muss von hand geräumt
werden schaufel für schaufel
je mehr schnee sich hier an den seiten
sammelt desto weniger platz haben die
züge bei der durchfahrt
gelingt es nicht die vollen 140 meter
der einhausung zu räumen das ist nicht
gut kann der versorgungs zug primo sema
denise restaurant in alb grün nicht
erreichen und dort essen viele
passagiere des bernina express zu mittag
wo gibt's denn sowas ein restaurant ohne
essen
crameri und sein team geben alles um den
tunnel zu räumen bevor alle züge auf der
einspurigen strecke stoppen müssen
wir stehen hier und warten auf unsere
lieferung aber aus erwarten können wir
nichts tun
in zwei minuten kommt ein zug wir müssen
raus
ich hoffe der zug kommt auch
keine minute zu früh verlässt er mit
fast zwei tonnen schnee beladener waggon
den tunnel
der nächste halt ist alb grün dort
machen wir einen 15-minütigen fotostopp
bis 11 und 22
sie können also gern aussteigen und
fotos machen
kurz vor dem ziel passiert der zug den
frisch geräumten tunnel
[Musik]
ist es ihr am bahnhof alb grün gibt es
ein restaurant ein kleines hotel und das
war es auch schon wenig später trifft
auch endlich der versorgungs zug ein
zügig beginnt die entladung
des wir müssen viel planen
auf
2091 metern über dem meeresspiegel bis
zimmer die auf die bahn angewiesen um
seinen lebensunterhalt zu sichern
zugführer danke
hier gibt es keine straßen oder
nein nach alb grün kommt man nur mit dem
zug
während das restaurant team die
passagiere des bernina express versorgt
gehen patricia und reto dem stromausfall
auf der zugtoilette nach vor seiner zeit
als fahrer hat reto eine ausbildung zum
mechaniker gemacht er prüft die
verkabelung am triebwagen er guckt nach
den kabeln
eines ist tatsächlich lose denken vielen
dank hoffentlich ist das problem damit
behoben die passagiere genießen derweil
schweizer spezialitäten das ist rötheli
ein likör mit kirche ziemlich süß
der wind stört beim einschenken runter
damit
lag uns stark
bei der abfahrt aus alb grün scheint
alles wieder nach plan zu laufen
ok sieht gut aus funktioniert wieder
alle probleme gelöst
als der zug die berge hinter sich lässt
nimmt der schnee ab und die täler öffnen
sich
normalerweise läuft alles aber manchmal
gibt es kleinere probleme oder ja
manchmal aber nicht oft
das liegt wohl an den passagieren
alle sind gut drauf es ist ein schöner
sonniger tag
aber ein stück weiter
dieser ganze bereiche
droht an einer felswand die katastrophe
auf der höchsten aktions bahn strecke
europas hat der zug den berninapass
erklommen von nun an geht es bergab der
zug lässt die alpen hinter sich und
fährt durch malerische schweizer dorf in
den tälern
in diesem zug zu arbeiten macht sie das
stolz auf ihr heimatland
es ist eine der beeindruckendsten
bahnstrecken überhaupt
der nächste halt ist ein dorf mit kaum
4000 einwohnern
[Musik]
ich bin ausgestiegen um frische luft zu
schnappen wir sind hier in poschiavo es
war noch in der schweiz aber in diesem
ort und diesem teil des landes wird
vorwiegend italienisch gesprochen hier
braucht man keine winterjacke das wetter
ist frühlingshaft das klima hat sich
seit den verschneiten bergen enorm
verändert richtig schön
schon bald geht es weiter mit einem
neuen fahrer john
ich fahre seit fast 40 jahren für die
rhätische bahn man ist draußen unterwegs
arbeitet aber trotzdem mit technik das
gefällt mir
auf der fahrt richtung süden geht es
entlang der uferlinie des lago di
poschiavo
patron hier keine lawinen mehr aber um
die ecke auf dem weg nach brusio lauern
andere gefahren
2008 gab es hier einen felssturz dabei
kamen 30 bis 40 tausend kubikmeter
gestein runter der zug wurde nicht
getroffen aber die strecke war fast drei
monate lang gesperrt wurden die schienen
dabei zerstört ja auf einer länge von
etwa 300 metern
ralf rechsteiner trug maßgeblich dazu
bei dass die schienen schnellstmöglich
etwas weiter vom berghang entfernt neu
verlegt wurden
etwa 50 meter in richtung tal das ganze
geschah innerhalb von 111 tagen nach dem
unfall
um so etwas künftig zu verhindern hält
rechsteiner auf der strecke ausschau
nach risikobereichen
machen wir es genau hier das ist gut
wir kalkulieren das risiko wir haben das
alle 100 meter gemacht es geht um
felsstürze überschwemmungen
schlammlawinen und erdrutschen
in gefährdeten gebieten wird die
zugstrecke durch bruchsteinmauern vor
erdrutschen geschützt
in diesem gesamten abschnitt hier setzen
wir auch auf netze
in hochrisiko gebieten werden neben der
strecke stabile aber flexible metall
netze gespannt die herabstürzenden
gestein zurückhaltend
juli die sicherheit der passagiere ist
das wichtigste für uns
rechsteiner steam sorgt dafür dass der
bernina-express seine fahrt gut
geschützt fortsetzen kann
südlich von brusio befindet sich das
wahrzeichen der berninalinie hier müssen
die schienen steiler als um die
machbaren 7 prozent abfallen
aber ein tunnel ließ sich im instabilen
gesteinigt anlegen also bauten
ingenieure eine 110 meter lange schleife
ins tal
das ist das kreisviadukt von brusio
darauf habe ich mich schon sehr gefreut
ein eingleisiger viadukt mit neuen böden
dass eine volle 360 grad kurve
beschreibt so kann der zug diesen
höhenunterschied schaffen
hinter dem viadukt geht es weiter nach
süden durch die kleinen schweizer orte
carpaccio und campo kolonie o
noch sind wir in der schweiz aber in ein
paar sekunden sind wir in italien
das ist auch toll an dieser zugfahrt man
bekommt gleich zwei länder geboten
jetzt sind wir in italien
hinter der grenze nimmt die reise eine
ungewöhnliche wendung
[Musik]
der berg zug wird zur straßenbahn
wir sind hier in tirano die häuser
stehen sehr nah an den schienen hier
verläuft die straße fußgänger und autos
kommen sehr nah an den zug vor allem im
sommer herrscht hier zur ferienzeit viel
verkehr ja da muss man aufpassen
das ist die basilika von tirano hier am
marktplatz echt interessant mit dem zug
quer durch die stadt zu fahren
solange es keine unfälle gibt und
niemand verletzt wird machte spaß
gerade kommt die durchsage dass wir fast
da sind es hat mir richtig gut gefallen
wie war es für sie ein toller tag auf
meiner lieblingsstrecke in meinem
lieblings zug was will man mehr eine
bemerkenswerte reise durch die alpen
geht zu ende auf dieser bahn strecke
werden wahrlich berge bezwungen und
pünktlich wie das sprichwörtliche
schweizer uhrwerk erreicht der zug sein
ziel
[Musik]
es ist der bahnhof tirano ist die
endstation für den bernina express es
war faszinierend innerhalb weniger
stunden durch so viele klimazonen und
höhenlagen zu reisen und den höchsten
eisenbahn pass der alpen zu überqueren
[Musik]